[Musique]
au pays de l'aragon il y avait une fille
qui aime et les gars ce citron et
vanille au pays de l'eu castille
avait-elle un garçon qui vend des dégâts
sont bannis et sinon moi j'aime mieux
les glace au chocolat paul roy mais j'ai
mon pain pis il n'y en a plus c'est bon
tu sais pourquoi je n'ai pas pris de
temps pour lui et je mangeais pour tous
des serbes du camembert le camembert ces
bons moments c'est bien fait la moue à
se confondre non donnant mon temps au
pays car la bâton il n'y avait plus le
figuier mais ceci qu'on éloigne au pays
le casting est un garçon qui vend des
glaces banny et c'est en vendre des
glaces et teintés pour mettez vos pieds
c'est beaucoup mieux que le marchand de
mort en pata pon manche amour on s'est
pas mal
ga parents qui en vendait pour les juifs
et les oiseaux n'achetez pas
féfé mes copains de moutons à ce propos
dans un no agneau au pays
l'aragon et y avait une fille qui aimait
les gars ce citron est pas mieux au pays
de legaspi gaffes et 9 garçons qui vend
des dégâts stéphanie et si tôt mais la
casse et ça n'est pas maradona mais non
et l'aragon ça n'est pas la question et
la fille s'est passé de glace aussi
qu'on a des manies et le garçon n'a rien
vendu nous tout a fondu dans un combat
ses manches dans le fond pompiers à
montpothier chandon jusqu'à demain au
pays de l'art at on y avait eu une fille
qui aimait les cas ce seront est bonne
meilleure mon pays
le casting avec un garçon vivant les
diverses familles et s'étend
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]